Speaker 1: One other note on Marjorie Taylor
GREENE Mike Pillow. His real name is Mike
Lindell. He's the CEO and founder of Mypillow.
Mike Pillow seems to be turning on Marjorie
Taylor. GREENE And this is the continued rift
within the pro-Trump wing of the Republican
Party. And Pillow is not happy with Marjorie
Taylor GREENE over her vote for Kevin McCarthy
and says she was probably bribed with some kind
of promise for something. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: You just think of this. I want you to
think of this. Look, when Matt gives put this out,
okay? It was seven. Was it the seventh
or eighth vote? Now, think of this. If
you did it right out of the gate, you got to
think of this as marketing, guys. You know,
if you it around the gate, it's not going to
fly you. I think right now it's happening just
the way it's going to unfold here. Where does
this end? It can only end with McCarthy giving
in. It's not going to be the other way. And I'm
telling you that I know these guys are if it if
they if they have made promises to the grassroots,
they've made promises to the people. Matt Gaetz is
not going to break his promise. And neither I'm
very surprised that the one I won't name or name,
but it's Marjorie Taylor GREENE Promise? We're
surprised you came. Oh, I let it slip on. Oh, you
can see my friend bashes Marjorie Taylor GREENE.
Oh, yeah. Yeah, that she. I mean, it's her choice,
but obviously, she was promised something.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So, listen, people get promise
stuff all the time. Pillow is not wrong. That
there's all sorts of horse trading and promises
and negotiation 100%. That's the case. The message
here, though, is when you've lost Mike Pillow,
but you are pro-Trump, that is a serious
rift. And of course, the hope is that this
degrades and destroys the Republican Party from
within. The most important aspect to this that I
think it's important to refresh is that at no
point were these 20 Republicans or the others,
none of them at any point were primarily concerned
with what is best for the American people. They
were concerned with publicity. They were concerned
with attention. Some of them were probably
concerned with staying in Trump's good graces.
They were concerned with all sorts of different
things. What can I negotiate for myself? How can
I seize power for myself? What was not on the list
is what is best for the American people was not
even a consideration. They turned on each other.
They turned back. Their friends. Their enemies.
You know? Look at Dan Crenshaw. You look at Matt
Gage. They are they with Trump, are they not?
They disagree here. They agree. They're whatever.
But never does it enter into the into the
calculus, what is best for the American people
here. And the proof continues to be presented in
the reality that after they finally agreed on a
speaker after 15 votes and Kevin McCarthy took
the gavel and the whole thing, the first thing
they went to was repealing the funding bill for
the IRS, which, by the way, they don't understand.
They're confused about and also has zero chance
of even becoming a reality because the Senate's
not going to repeal it. And if they tried to, Joe
Biden would veto it. It's going nowhere. It's just
a waste of time. The idea of, hey, what did the
American people need? What might be useful to the
American people? Why don't we look at health care
and getting people health care? Why don't we look
at education? Why don't we look at climate? Why
don't we look at energy? Why don't we look at all
these different. Now, what about repealing the IRS
thing, which we don't even understand? They do not
care about the American people. And much like,
you know, we had these viral interviews and Luke
Beasley would do some for us at Trump events.
He would ask people, what do you like the most
about what Trump did? And the answers were either
something Trump didn't actually do or something
Trump did that has absolutely no impact on
their lives whatsoever or has a negative impact.
Give it six months now of Republican control in
the House. Give it a year, and then we'll go out
and interview these very same people and say, what
is the Republican House done? It will either be
things they haven't done, things they did that are
damaging, or the third one that you're going to
see as well. They haven't been able to do anything
because of Democrats in the Senate. That's going
to be the explanation. We're ready for it. It's
unfortunately very depressing. One of our sponsors
today is Xypex nicotine toothpicks. Xypex brings
you a convenient alternative to smoking and vaping
and the vapor clouds, the ashtrays, the thing
in your lip that people can see. I've seen that
around. This is an easier and less messy way to
curb the cravings. And you can use xypex just
about anywhere. Xypex is available in six flavors
with two or three mg strength. The nicotine and
the flavor are long lasting and Xypex has helped
countless people kick the bad habits and they are
bad habits. Xypex toothpicks are FDA registered.
Their customer service is second to none. It is
one of the most cost effective alternatives. Also,
check out their B12 and caffeine toothpicks. See
for yourself why so many people have switched to
Xypex toothpicks. You can only get xypex online.
Go to Xypex toothpick scum and get 10% off
with the code Packman. The link is down below.